bla bla bla bla bla
hallo mein name zu kommen als die musik
die musik
sorry aber ich finde das sieht einfach
viel zu greifen wir haben uns hier
versammelt weil youtube mich hasst das
ist ein rundgang nachrichten vielleicht
werde ich noch alles wieder was ich
gestern hochgeladen habe wenn ich sende
ich euch jetzt mal ganz kurzen
ausschnitt davon 1
exakt trifft dann auch schon das video
wurde entfernt danke youtube ich bin ich
richtig kennt man geht nicht gleich ich
selbst auch wurde es dreckig ich freue
mich auf jeden fall heute morgen 12 uhr
in die youtube studio ab gegangen wo man
genau sehen kann welches video
hochgeladen hat et cetera pp habe ich
mir das video von gestern anguckt um zu
schauen was und dafür kommentare was
sagen die leute und dann steht da auf
einmal das dümmste video auf youtube
soll ich das ja genannt die dio entfernt
unangemessene inhalte steht da ein
fucking käding
ich kann euch doch noch zeigen zwei ich
kann das noch sehen hier aber nicht ich
zeige euch mal irgendwie was also stehen
halt darum ich habe mir kultivierte
akribisch genau das ist auf jeden fall
das video was ich gestern hochgeladen
habe das haben auch ganz gut bei euch an
die vorgeschichte dazu es halt ich hab
letztens mal ein video hochgeladen wo
ich mich selber gegoogelt habe und
dieses video kamen weil es den namen
trug als zu dumm und zu erste kamps hat
als ich den namen luca gebügelt habe und
dann habe ich halt den dem buckel hast
mich video was ihr euch hier mal
verlinke irgendwo da könnt ihr euch das
mal schon das ist nämlich noch verfügbar
danke dafür youtube da habe ich gefragt
wie auch solch ein komplettes wieder
machen die ich nur auf dieses video
reagiere und alle meine saison macht das
mal und ich hab das ja selbst schon oft
gemacht dass ich auch videos reagiere
und voll für die youtuber und youtube
kanäle bestehen nun raus das video von
anderen youtuber an reagiert wird und
ich bekomme direkten habe ich einen
streit bekommen baloise gruppe aus der
zukunft das ist eine kleine nachricht an
luca aus der vergangenheit und zwei
jahre luca lo huston strike dass ich
stehe nämlich in einem youtube com
zuständig einwandfrei bei den community
richtlinien das heißt ich habe einen
warnhinweis und bin scheiße aber jetzt
macht ganz normal weiter mit deinem
video can't wieder als ist weil
die korrekten verstoßen was ist eine
renn deutschland vergessen geburtstag
ein bisschen was getrunken deswegen sehe
ich auch bisschen fertig aus meiner haut
das geht überhaupt nicht klar aber heute
übels aktionen alter ich bin mit einem
ganz alten heute aber von meinem vater
umgefahren
hier ein paar szenen davon ein ich hab
das snap chat gepolstert ist ja im block
alter da ist ja alles von mir
und das war einfach so richtig schöne
urteil zu kommen alte mann das ganze
wind gewerkt und schilder benzingeruch
und er tut gar nichts zur sache
jedenfalls sehe ich deswegen so ein
bisschen zerzaust aus einerseits gestern
geburtstag warum gerade cabrio gefahren
bin möglichkeit einzeltest entfernt
wurde weil ich ihren video hochgeladen
habe quasi das sozusagen kopiert habe
sage ich mal möglichkeit zwei und das
halte ich für wahrscheinlicher walter
teils steht abgelehnt und angemessener
inhalt ist einfach weil die apfelmus
essen das aus kosten und weil die sagen
guckt euch meine nase an alter ohne spaß
ich bin so ein politischer mensch alter
ich ließ der zeit gefühlt stündlich 430
mal die beiden jungs in dem video sagen
auf jeden fall solle passage wie nazis
rein juden raus das gas rein irgendwie
so ein scheiß so total rechtsradikale
kaka hat und ich glaube deswegen wird
entfernt und ich frage mich wieso mein
video entfernt wurde das von denen vier
jahre online sein kann
youtube nach ihm folgt tätigen hier
konnten wir heute auf jeden fall wieder
videos bei twitter zu sendung darauf
wollte ich eigentlich reagieren da kam
ein beispielsweise so was an sie mal
dein herz und streicht es durch und
streicht es noch mal durch und mal
drüber und mal den smiley an und ja auch
solche videos wollte ich eigentlich
reagieren allerdings habe ich halt dann
in der bi hat gesehen dass mein video
runter genommen wurde deswegen weil ich
darüber reden weil ich schon nachrichten
kommen luca will wieder von gestern
damit das video aber nicht komplett ohne
sinn ist habe ich noch drei sachen kurz
zu sagen das erste ist es geht bald im
lukas shop einer rechts kissen die
kommen bald wirklich ein weißes kit mit
dem schwarzen ist my dear drauf so das
wird echt nice ich hatte da schon das
ist cook das ist echt nice und
zeitgleich damit kommen diese beiden t
shirts in den shop also viele hatten ja
gesagt sie wollen so was wie der rudi
ist der video gibts ja so quasi not
anhalt als rudi sind das jetzt t shirts
in den beiden variationen sind
ich komme bald in den shop wenn ihr euch
darauf freuen wenn sie da bock drauf
habt dass die vielleicht nicht nur
limitiert kommen sondern dauerhaft drin
sind sagen man mit einer bewertung
limitierte sachen sind bei mir irgendwie
mal direkt weg das in den shop kommen
gibt es dann auch wieder irgendwie 1000
signiertes dicker von mir die ihr beim
kauf vor dem t shirt oder kissen oder
ezb-rat kriegen kann also das wollte ja
noch kurz ankündigen dritte sache ich
komme nicht zum web video preis viele
hat mich deswegen fragen so luca bild
zum video bereichen kommen die sache ist
wenn ich nominiert worden wäre wäre ich
als safe gekommen da ich das allerdings
nicht mit kanäle nominiert zu
durchdenken
warum werde ich gott
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht hinkommen
ja das war so ganz kurz amanda und
letzte sache ich habe mich letztes in
den einkaufswagen gesetzt und komplett
mich dabei gefilmt und ich habe daraus
seine data day the day monday parodie
gemacht die 30 sekunden des extra
richtig schlecht gemacht ich wollte dir
euch vielleicht morgen in minecraft
video zeigen habt ihr da bock drauf oder
nicht weil also wenn ihr es ja zeit mal
das ist echt so behindert dargestellt
dann lade ich das morgen hoch oder sonst
halt nicht an dieser stelle band nicht
auch das heutige video und wollte
eigentlich wirklich auf twitter videos
reagieren weil das immer ultra coole
sind echt sowas von verstörende videos
bei rumgekommen das werde ich jetzt aber
die tage einfach dann hochladen ich
wollte euch heute darüber informieren
dass ich jetzt kein deutsch kann und
andererseits mein video von gestern
entfernt wurde
deswegen hier mit bitteschön für die
info ich weiß das video hatte eigentlich
gar keinen sinn wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen hat sagt er gibt mir einen
daumen hoch ich zeige euch auch mal ganz
kurz war es die ganzen geschenke von
fans treffen sind angekommen
und da sind halt solche sachen bei so
ukulelen die ihr mir gebastelt habt und
ich habe glaube ich allein 56 uhr ihren
geschenkt bekommen ich frage euch jetzt
nochmal hier ganz offiziell wollt ihr
dass ich am sonntag uncut wirklich alle
geschenke mann aus packte also ich denke
die briefe sortiert vorher außerdem
steht ultra viele handynummer anderen
schreibt wendy kommentare lassen leiter
60.000 likes schafft ihr nicht oder ich
weiß nicht wieso ambitioniert
dieses video ich hasse solche videos
hochzuladen das nicht so info videos an
youtube hochladen was ich will wenn ihr
euch beschwert verpisst euch schön dass
ich immer so nett wird am ende von dem
video
ich hab euch trotzdem lieb